hallo hier ist wieder einmal panne und
ich habe mir bei mir
wir machen nämlich zusammen ein
coloration cola oder cola zum premium
und zwar hab ich sie auf meinem kanal
ums zeit und wenn ihr auf ihrem kanal
geht seht ihr wie ich umgestellt werden
tischtennis ist das und lust und los
geht's ich habe ja nicht vorher gesagt
was ich schmecke und sie muss es dann am
ende erwarten da kann ich voll vertraue
geschminkt ist immer so schön in einem
video das man kann gar nicht abonniert
haben das gesehen warum boxt nicht auf
twitter und auch nicht
und jetzt mache ich ihre augenbrauen ich
verlängere die vorne ein bisschen
verlängern müssen die augenbrauen person
die das immer treten kann sie natürlich
[Applaus]
ich mache jetzt deine lippen welche
verrückte ich hab hier so'n gar nicht
natürlichen hin
ich hab hier sind ganz natürlich einen
bären tor das ist total schwierig deine
lippen zwar etwas und dünn
das ist wie zwei strich aber dann
verständnis du nicht so viel lippenstift
macht auch noch s creed ist als
allerletztes mache ich dir wimperntusche
drauf die person wie das trägt trägt mir
nicht alles echt aufpassen ich bin halt
nicht berührt
jetzt mache ich noch deine haare auf
dann haben wir doch auch echt kreuzen
das ist nicht so typisch für mädchen ja
ja also jeder für wie er mag natürlich
nach jeder dort seine haare aber nicht
so mädchen kleid stellt hier schon mal
ein paar fragen so dass ich kann ja
schon mal ein paar tipps geben in welche
richtung das kind ok wenig bekannt ja
wenn ich auf youtube youtube
ja bin ich schön bis auf jeden tag ein
anderes outfit und das ist mein fertiger
look hast es längst schon erraten dass
wir vielleicht sagen was die youtube
videos zu sagen
die kenntnisse dann okay zum beispiel
einsatz von iris ton ein hoffentlich
setzt sich nicht nehmen dem user der
klasse mache ich mir die videos schon
mal ich bin ja sehr schön war es auf
jeden fall beauty wies aber ich nur mal
sex macht auch hier habe ich einen
freund du hast auch ein freund was macht
mein freund dein freund sieht eigentlich
meistens ziemlich dumm aus in allem was
er tut er kann mit schauspielern er kann
nicht moderieren
der ist einfach nicht für die kamera
gemacht aber man sieht ihn ziemlich oft
als wichtigste ist dass du immer ganz
gerade setzten und du siehst immer
perfekt auf lächelt auch ganz groß wenn
du redest halte weiterhin genauso ist
auch ganz schusselig immer was ihr
wasser was gebe ich noch für tipps an
junge leute weiter also ein tipp von mir
ist dass man in der schule mit nicht so
vielen jungs rumknutschen sollte weil
man dann eine [ __ ] ist und dann ist
man nur so eine die zum knutschen gut
ist und nicht für eine feste zahl wird
sich keiner mehr dich verlieben sagt sie
und was ist wenn ich schon drei jungs
geknutscht
also dann bist du leider ja eine
[ __ ] hast du schon jetzt werde ich
echt schusselig ich hab das wichtigste
vergessen du kannst ja gar nicht drauf
kommen kann man die augen zu gut dass du
so eine große stirn
fertig du willst lauren coco xo und wenn
jetzt unser zweites umstyling sehen
wollt geht bitte auf mehrere das
camargue kriegt auf mein gesicht hat es
bestimmt verregneten hinter infobox
genau wer möchte nicht ins gesicht
blicken ich auf jeden fall gibt solchen
leuten keine chance schreibt ich nicht
auch lernen denken und schreiben
[Musik]
ich denke das ist so eine künstliche um
armut danke mir da ist dies aus